determine whether the ordered pairs 3
comma 5 and 1 comma negative 7 are
solutions to the inequality 5x minus 3y
is greater than or equal to 25 so we can
literally just try each of these ordered
pairs we could try what happens when X
is equal to 3 and Y is equal to 5 in
this inequality and see if it satisfies
it and then we could try it for 1 and
negative 7 so let's do that first let's
do it first 4 3 & 5 so when X is 3 y is
5 let's see if this actually gets
satisfied so we get 5 times 3 5 times 3
let me color code it so this is 5 I did
want to do in that color 5 times 3 5
times 3 minus 3 times 5 minus 3 times 5
let's see if this is greater than if
this is greater than or equal to 25 so 5
times 3 is 15 and then from that we're
going to subtract we're going to
subtract 15 and let's see if that is
greater than or equal to 25 but that
question mark there because we don't
know and 15 minus 15 that is 0 so we get
the expression 0 is greater than or
equal to 25 this is not true 0 is less
than 25 so this is not true this is not
true so this ordered pair is not a
solution to the inequality so this is
not not a solution
you put in X is 3 y is 5 you get 0 is
greater than or equal to 25 which is
absolutely not true now let's try it
with 1 and negative 7 so we have 5 times
1 minus 3 times negative 7 needs to be
greater than or equal to 25 5 times 1 is
5 and then minus 3 times negative 7 is
negative 21 so it becomes minus negative
21 used to be greater than or equal to
25 this
the same thing as 5 plus 21 subtracting
a negative same thing as adding the
positive is greater than or equal to 25
and 5 plus 21 is 20 6 is indeed greater
than greater than or equal to 25 so this
works out so this is a solution and just
to see if we can visualize this a little
bit better I'm going to graph this
inequality I'm not going to show you
exactly how I do it this time but I'm
going to show you where these points lie
relative to this solution so first let's
put this in point so if we have so we
have five we just in a new color so we
have 5 X that's not a new color having
trouble switching colors today we have
5x minus 3y is greater than or equal to
25 let me write this inequality in kind
of our slope-intercept form so this
would be the same thing if we subtract
5x from both sides we get negative 3y is
greater than or equal to negative 5x
plus 25 I just subtracted 5x from both
sides so that gets eliminated you have a
negative 5x over here now let's divide
both sides of this equation or I should
say this inequality by negative 3 and
when you divide both sides of an
inequality by a negative number multiply
or divide by a negative number it swaps
the inequality so if you divide both
sides by negative 3 you get Y is less
than or equal to negative 5 divided by
negative 3 is 5 over 3x and then 25
divided by negative 3 is minus minus 25
over 3 so if I were to graph this so
this is now the expression or the
inequality Y is less than or equal to 5
3 X minus 25 over 3 so if I wanted to
graph this I'll try to draw a relatively
rough graph here but really just so that
we can visualize this really so we can
visualize it
so our y-intercept is negative 25 over 3
that's the same thing as negative 8 and
one-third so that's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and
a little bit more than 8 so our
y-intercept is
negative eight and a third like that and
has a slope of five thirds so that means
for every three it goes to the right it
rises five so it goes one two three it
rises five it rises five so the line is
going to look something like this I'm
drawing a very rough version of it so
the line will look something like that
this line over here that's if it was y
is equal to 5/3 X minus 25 over 3 but
here we have an inequality it's y is
less than or equal to so for any for any
X the Y's that satisfy it are the Y that
equals 5/3 X minus 25 over 3 that would
be on the line so it would be that point
there and all the Y's less than it so
the solution is this whole area right
over here
since it's less than or equal to we can
include the line the equal to allows us
to include the line and less then tells
us we're going to go below the line and
we can verify that by looking at these
two points over here we saw that 3 comma
5 is not part of the solution so 3 comma
5 is 1 to 2 right about there and then
up 5 so 3 comma 5 is right above here
it's in this region above the line and
notice not part of the solution and then
1 comma negative 7 1 comma negative 7 is
going to be right over here it's almost
on the line so 1 comma negative 7 is
going to be right over there but it is
at least within this solution area so
hopefully that gives you a little bit
more sense of how to visualize these
things and we'll cover this in more
detail in future videos